[Musique]
les garçons 1 6i dont ils sont fiers et
les fines en ont pas c'est le constat
que font les petits hommes de 4 à 6 pour
eux un besoin urgent est une simple
formalité mais pour nathalie par exemple
c'est une autre affaire leur petit bout
de virilité confère bien des avantages
aux garçons et d'abord le droit
d'affirmer une malle supériorité y
compris un coup de poing
qui pleure le plus souvent ça les filles
ou les garçons
[Musique]
parce que vous le talent et sir
toujours
[Musique]
voilà un garçon assez costaud donc super
fière sa force il la cultive toute la
journée ils jouent au football pas les
filles aux cowboys pas les filles les
grimpe aux arbres et filles trop
délicate se consacre à des activités
plus poétique
j'ai envie de jouer à la dînette des
fois
y'a de poupée
d'accord c'est ta poupée à toi et c'est
pas une poupée comme celle des filles la
pompe à mon front
pourtant quelque chose chez les filles
intrigue ces matches où en culottes
courtes un petit rien qu'ils possèdent
mal pas du tout et on ressent parfois au
royaume des garçons comme une pointe de
jalousie qui n'est du côté des petites
six
chaînes
qu'est ce que c'est les chaînes
mais autour du cou donc on trouve en
europe que des dits valides on
l'attendait jim et des pantalons que
tandis qu elles l ont parfois les papas
nom des rues parce que l ces défis l on
doit connaître ses pantalons et des
robes
safran tout droit montré des robes et
autres fonds et des robes
tu préfères comment les filles avaient
en jean ou bien en robe
ya pas une petite amie une que tu
préfères
ya pas une amoureuse
comment tu les choisis
eh bien on le connaît on sait comment on
se connaît un jour et puis on sent bien
tu vas te marier plus tard quand tu
seras grand
comment tu vois ça
[Musique]
tu sais pas
comment tu vas la choisir à l'intérieur
c'est pas lui c'est ce que nous a dit
qu'une loi de la jungle avec des laudes
alors gérant pas comment faire moi
[Musique]